When I was in grade school,
I looked up to my father and my grandfather
who were both lawyers,
and so when I was really young,
I think I sort of just thought
that I would somehow move and follow in their path
and become a lawyer.
But as I got older,
I started to get a lot more interested in technology,
so when I was in my teenage years
and in high school,
I realized that there was huge opportunity
and that's where the world was going,
that computers were soon going to be everywhere,
and we needed the software
and the technology to evolve.
That led me into the world of software and technology
and building tools and the Internet.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.